so you and i want to fight poverty and
one of the things that we've clicked on
is that
web3 technologies have the potential to
be one of the most profound
opportunities
to combat poverty that maybe we have
ever seen certainly 100
100
100 at the end of the day we can sit
here and celebrate
covers of magazines or write tons of
articles about the next uh crypto
billionaire
and celebrate that person like it's the
greatest thing
since
you know jesus christ but at the end of
the day
like we should be ashamed of ourselves
like we're creating wealth
in
the most expansive time in history for
people that more often than not not to
say this is the case all the time but
that more often than not we're already
good
while we sit here and there's
populations like the good zone in dc in
southwest washington dc where the
average income is 14 000 a year wow and
we think that
that's perfectly acceptable
like you and i also agree on the point
that poverty is a social construct that
doesn't need to exist totally
unnecessary you know financial
technologies that have been created
recently like cryptocurrencies
um and the utilization of web 3 is the
latest sort of iteration of how we can
do it it obviously allows us to do it at
a much quicker and more efficient pace
but we could have eradicated poverty a
long time ago
and this has been a relatively recent
shift though we've been we've been able
to do it for years but there was a
period when there was genuine scarcity
and not enough to go around but we
passed that point we don't live in that
time now we don't live in that time now
the second that they started building
them rockets
that looked like dildos and shooting
them up to the moon
the time had come and gone where you
could tell me that people need to be
living on the street i agreed completely
unacceptable like completely honest it
was actually pre spaceship even like we
could have done this stuff the thing
that really lit a fire under me in my
brain
was during the financial crisis 2008
2009
markets crashing et cetera et cetera
they print four trillion dollars to
shore up wall street
more or less
and i don't remember voting for it no
one was voting for it i don't remember
anyone being like where we get the money
et cetera et cetera but i got to tell
you darius i i saw that [ __ ] and was
like we just did what we just printed
four trillion dollars to essentially
make the banks whole
uh and i took from that
this incredible
revelation
that if we wanted to we could have
produced four trillion dollars worth of
wealth good services for the american
people
at any point up to then you know
if a push came to shove
and i genuinely think
that we are still dealing with the
anger and the aftermath of that
financial crash
because that financial crash and now it
seems like ancient history because it's
you know
uh
13 14 years ago now
but it gave rise to the tea party
uh it gave rise to just a lot of
populist anger where up up until then it
was not clear
to me even
uh it was not clear to me how
rigged and jacked up the game was until
they
pulled that
printer lever for the 4 trillion
uh in
08.
after that i was like we can do anything
uh and here we are i mean when i was
running for president on this stuff
people were always like oh where you get
the money where you get the money and
then we just did it again for
uh covert relief which by the way i was
you know all for some version of it the
problem was that so little of that went
to the people in the good zone or people
around the country
i did the math is like 17 of it went to
people and families 83 of it went to
banks airlines
giant firms and now they're finding out
that a lot of the money that got plowed
to these companies didn't go to payroll
preservation or whatever the heck it you
know like so which was by the way
entirely predictable like if you wanted
to you could reverse that and been like
hey guess what we're gonna
send the money straight to the employees
send the money straight to the people
and then you can figure out like the
you know the corporate balance sheet
yourselves i mean that would have been a
very dramatic way to do it but i would
have been for it i think if you'd asked
any american hey
we're going to print two trillion
dollars uh do you want 83 of it to go to
the corporates or 83 of it to go to
you know
you and your neighbors um so i've been
after this more or less since
uh 08
that we have entered an era of
abundance if we want that for our people
but it turns out that our government
doesn't really respond to
the people
uh and
start man you better start and that's
what we need to change but you and i are
going to work on activating
the
value creation of web3 technologies to
help the people that you're serving
in the good zone
and other people
around the country as quickly as
possible because you're right that right
now
it's not addressing
the
imbalances and ills the way that it
could and it's going to be good for
everyone if we can
uh bring
the opportunity to the need
100
if you think about just the foundation
of cryptocurrencies the foundation this
is pre-sub-road days got a bad rep
during that time you know
cryptocurrencies were created
as a financial vehicle to provide access
to capital to communities that otherwise
wouldn't
most often than not communities that
would didn't have access to the outsider
system yeah
and
somewhere along the line
we let greed creep in the same way that
we do again so many other things with
this deficit mindset
where
when we step out here and we make these
bold claims that okay we're going to
utilize
the blockchain or web3 technologies to
be able to provide more access to
capital to communities people will look
at us like oh my god
that's so crazy to think about it's like
no this is what it was made for in the
first place we just put it on cash app
and then it became a thing where we're
like oh it's a commodity now because
there's a dollar value associated with
it
right but again back to my earlier point
as we sit here and celebrate how much
wealth is being created in this moment
we should sit here and be ashamed of
ourselves how let's not help people as
much as it could or should yeah more
often that wealth is not touching those
that truly need it yeah it's true
[Music]
you